this episode is brought to you by movie
[Music]
what's up guys michael here with a new
episode of book vs
film today we want to chat about one of
literature and cinema's greatest heroes
a true
mensch the kind of guy you can really
root for
just kidding we're talking american
psycho
and of course the titular psycho patrick
bateman
both the film and novel have engendered
serious controversy
author bretty stenalis received numerous
death threats after the book's
publication
and leonardo dicaprio was talked out of
starring in the film by feminist
activist gloria steinem
and both versions are provocative
brutally violent and often
quite funny i'm into uh murders and
executions mostly
do you like it well it depends
why well most guys i know who work in
mergers and acquisitions
really don't like it but they're also
two very distinct works and their
differences can affect the way we
interpret them
what's more the differences raise some
pretty cool questions
like is the book boring on purpose or
what happens to the meaning of a scene
when you flip the perspective
so instead of comparing business cards
let's compare american psycho book
versus film
and obviously spoilers ahead for both
let's start by looking at the
similarities both follow the same
fundamental timeline
which sees label obsessed has a boner
for a good business card yuppie patrick
bateman
as he goes from saying and thinking
violent things to living his very best
serial killer life
he takes out his anger on unhoused
people sex workers and the occasional
wealthy foe
in the meantime he has a complete
meltdown and pretends to stagger
reservation at dorsia
we're totally booked really that's great
no i said we are totally booked
two at nine perfect see you then on top
of the same basic trajectory
many of the film's best moments are
cribbed directly from
the novel from bateman losing his [ __ ]
over a rival's business card to his
confused homoerotic encounter
to some choice quotes about women if
they have a good personality and they're
not
great looking then who cares just say
hypothetically okay what if they have a
good personality
i know i know there are no girls with
good personalities
but of course if they were carbon copies
this video would be over
and you'd be very bored while there are
plenty of things the movie leaves out
presumably for time
we're talking about the changes that
feel most important
which brings us to the differences we
spent a lot of time picking apart
american psycho to find these
comparisons
there is nothing we love more than a
movie that requires some over
analyzation it's one of the best parts
about movie going and if you feel the
same
then we think you should check out this
week's sponsor mubi mubi is a curated
streaming service showing exceptional
films from around the globe
every day movie premieres a new film
from timeless classics to festival fresh
gems there's always something new to
discover every movie they show is hand
selected and includes an hour take
explaining
why the film is worth your time they
also feature director retrospectives
thematic specials and
more it's like your own personal film
festival right in your home
right now you can check out the
exclusive streaming premiere of the
celebrated dramedy
give me liberty a hit at sundance and
khan and the winner of the john
cassady's award
at this year's indie spirit awards you
can check this out and also discover
hundreds of other great films
hand-picked by movies curators for free
all you have to do is head to movie.com
wisecrack
to get 30 days free that's movie.com
wisecrack for a whole month of great
cinema for free
now back to the show difference number
one
the violence most conversations about
american psycho
inevitably revolve around the violence
so let's start there
while both the film and the novel have
plenty to offer any fan of gory horror
there's really no comparison the
violence in the novel is by our rough
estimates
at least 650 percent more horrifying
more explicit more creative and more
innocence destroying than the film on
screen
much of the violence is alluded to a
woman will disappear and then reappear
on screen with a bloody nose
blood will splatter as a victim is
impaled in the face but we won't
actually
see that poor face or patrick will
lovingly finger a lock of hair of one of
his presumed victims
like a total freak by contrast easton
alice's depictions of the most deranged
violence
the worst of which is reserved for women
attack you and your poor brain like
you're the one being hit in the head
with a nail gun bateman tortures his
victims with steak knives
rips many eyeballs out of many sockets
and cooks one of his victims into a
human sausage while
sobbing and says i can't tell if i'm
cooking any of this correctly
because i'm crying too hard
and i have never really cooked anything
before
to be clear he's talking about a human
body oh and he also tries to mail the
shriveled heart of another victim to her
mom
and also stabs a child and pushes his
dying body behind a garbage can
and that's not even the worst of it it's
just what we think
might not get as demonetized the
comparatively toned down violence in the
film
seems like a reasonable change film is a
much more
stimulating medium there are things we
can tolerate in written form that might
just be too much for us on screen
director mary herron and screenwriter
gwenevere turner were
meticulous about calibrating what types
of violence counted as
satire versus exploitation at what point
to seeing a woman's body harmed on
screen stop making
a point and start making a really gross
and troubling statement
however there's an argument to be made
though i'm not sure if i'm buying it
that it's the book's violence that makes
it so effective
as a scathing commentary on 1980s greed
and superficiality
and rendering bateman so shocking so
absurdly and derangedly violent
the book ensures that we'll forgive him
nothing while movie bateman is gross and
awful and
very very disturbing his behavior
doesn't even near the book's standard of
violence
it's possible that the movie's relative
restraint shielded the audience from
some of the book's impact by concealing
the worst of bateman's violence
in the movie he's deranged sure but in
the book he's
positively inhuman someone we can't
identify with
in contrast movie maven is still revered
by certain corners of dude culture
in 2005 a bateman action figure was in
high demand
these days and i'm not making this up
the bateman skincare line has brought
masculine vanity to the masses
and lots of men dream of imitating his
well quaffed ways
we're not saying the books over the top
violence is better especially
if you don't want to spring for therapy
after we're just saying that each works
approach to the violence
creates its own unique meaning in the
context of the narrative
okay enough about pan-frying human flesh
for one video
because the violence isn't the only big
difference if you've read the book
you might have noticed it's well boring
which brings us to difference number two
the movie is enthralling
and unlookawayable the book is often
boring as hell
on purpose mary herron's film adaptation
is brisk pacing and
is in academic terms a goddamn blast
from beginning to end
the book is something else entirely
this 400 page screed is on easton
ellis's part
above all meant to be a scathing take on
yuppie culture
as a result he wants you to hate this
particular yuppie and as we mentioned
before in regards to
human bratwurst he really succeeds by
making bateman not only 100
psychopath but also 100 boring as
hell the film might share some of the
novels banal and comedic conversations
about material wealth
but in the book bateman becomes even
more hateable with recurring passages
documenting his superficial obsessions
that are so boring as to be utterly
intolerable
here he is describing a christmas party
buffet
a long folding table has been covered
with a red tablecloth
and is jammed with pans and plates and
bowls of roasted hazelnuts
and lobster and oyster bisques and
celery root soup with apples and balloon
caviar on toast points
and creamed onions and roast goose with
chestnut stuffing
don't worry there's more and caviar and
puff pastry and vegetable tarts with
tapenade
roast duck and roast reactive veal with
shallots
and a vegetable sterling all of our
salad and scallops and bruschetta with
mascarpone and white truffles and green
chili souffle
there's still more but you get the
picture and
yell at us in the comments all you want
but we
know that you know that you are at least
a little bored during that 4 page
dissertation on whitney houston
being inside patrick bateman's head is a
lot of things but it's at most points
aggressively and decidedly
unfun his obsession with the finer
things in life has spiraled into
something completely
deranged sometimes that means
diagramming
every single designer behind every
single piece of clothing
on every single person in this fancy ass
new southern californian restaurant
until you wish he would gouge
your eyeballs out sometimes that means
reciting every single appliance or
decoration
in his sad expensive minimalist
apartment and that
always means describing every piece of
fancy food on the table
including the side dish condiments and
some very merry 80s sorbet flavors
in the film we get a fair amount of
voice over offering
some insight into the complete and utter
banality of being patrick bateman
after i remove the ice pack i use a deep
pore cleanser lotion
in the shower i use a water activated
gel cleanser
then a honey almond body scrub in both
versions
his inner monologue spotlights the
compulsive nature of someone who's
unable to experience life beyond luxury
commodities
sex and violence but in the book there's
no
escaping that inner monologue more than
anything
this speaks to the relative freedom the
fiction writers are given in comparison
to screenwriters and filmmakers
easton ellis can rant for seven and a
half pages about huey lewis in the news
but that's gotta be condensed to a one
and a half minute still long feeling
monologue as he prepares to
axe his business rival film structure is
for the most
part much more rigid you've basically
got to hit a compelling mid point by the
end of the first hour
it's almost impossible to fit more than
400 pages into two
hours and it makes sense that the
redundancies like the
count'em 15 references to donald trump
would be the first to go
instead of seemingly dozens of
conversations about stuff like
how to wear a vest beneath a suit we get
an errant line
now john you've got to wear clothes in
proportion to your physique
instead of a gajillion scenes fighting
over reservations
we get a quick conversation as a result
movie bateman is more tolerable
and much more entertaining in contrast
being inside bateman's head for 400
pages
reveals the absolute banality of yuppie
existence in all its armani drenched
glory
however patrick bateman isn't the only
character in the sordid tale
what about the women let's break it down
difference number three
the female perspective it doesn't take a
lot of reflection to realize that
patrick's malevolence has a favorite
target
women but through small changes in
perspective the film is able to do
things the book
otherwise can't easton ellis's novel is
situated so deeply in the crevices of
patrick bateman's disturbing brain
that there's no escaping his perspective
and when it comes to women let's just
say that perspective is
less than flattering the nicest thing
he'll call a woman he's about to murder
is a hard body which hopefully we don't
have to explain to you
is absolutely dehumanizing whether he's
feeding his fiance
a urinal cake disguised as a good dive
at chocolate or
swearing at his ex as he laces her in
the eyes while nailing her fingers to a
piece of wood
he displays nothing but disdain and
scorn for 99.9
of women with perhaps the exception of a
secretary
gene what's more the book's depiction of
the women is overwhelmingly a mirror
image of the men narcissistic
petty and craven in their obsession with
the material world
however while male superficiality is the
name of bateman's game
hearing it from women really grinds his
goat like evelyn obsessing over her
waldorf salad they have the best waldorf
salad in town at the rainbow room
did you like mine did you like my
waldorf salad honey
these depictions necessarily make it
harder to connect with the women bateman
wounds emotionally and
physically his rotes dehumanizing
descriptions of either sexing or
torturing women
start to blur together in contrast the
film
both written and directed by women
treats the female characters differently
in part because we're somewhat free from
the prison of bateman's perspective
now if you really pay attention you'll
find that not a single male character
says
anything that isn't remarkably petty
superficial or narcissistic
they prattle on about sex food and
clothes to such access as to seem
completely devoid of personality in
contrast the women in the film though
displaying varying levels of
superficiality
generally possess some emotional depth
outside the prism of bateman's narration
this allows us to genuinely feel for
them
there's evelyn watching her relationship
fall apart in slow motion
patrick we should do it
[Music]
do one get married have a wedding
no i can't take the time off work and
wondering out loud why bateman's
incapable of feeling you're inhuman
no i'm i'm in touch with humanity in the
book
this exchange is annoying for bathing
who tells us
to me she looks like a big black ant a
big black ant in an original christian
lacroix
eating a urinal cake and i almost start
laughing
but in the film we genuinely feel for
american icon reese witherspoon
and of course there's gene who adores
bateman with a startling innocence in
both iterations
while all of these basic narratives
exist in the novel they're so
filtered through bateman's [ __ ] that
we simply can't feel for the women the
way we do in the film
but the character who's most interesting
to us is christy
right before her first threesome with
bateman she exchanges a look with the
other sex worker that demonstrates their
mutual scorn for him
while that look is described in the
novel it's again filtered through
patrick's view
he doesn't actually pick up on the
extent to which these ladies
hate him the second time christy goes
back to his apartment
accepting his generous check presumably
out of desperation
the book describes her as cautious
scared and impassive
however in the film her solemn
performance and deadly glare are
uncomfortable to watch
here we see what she likely felt in the
book a hatred for bateman that he was
too self-centered to even notice
but it's when on-screen christy is
murdered that things get really tragic
and cinematically interesting in the
novel she's brutally tortured in ways so
shocking that we will unfortunately
remember them on our death beds
in the film things happen very
differently now in an earlier moment we
see patrick doing sit-ups while watching
texas chainsaw massacre which is for
sure
totally normal and chill thing to do but
it's also a sly reference to what
christy's death will look like
in the book christy is tied up and
gagged while patrick kills the other
member of their threesome
in the film she realizes he's attacking
the other woman promptly leaps up and
tries to get the hell
out what follows her running from
bateman in his chainsaw
is shot quite similarly to this moment
in that iconic horror film where the
protagonist runs for her life
also trying to escape a madman with a
chainsaw
so for a brief moment in the film we are
completely immersed in christy's
headspace
we can completely empathize with her and
we desperately want to see her escape
perhaps more so than any character in
the film christy is a real person who
sees bateman for what he really is
humanizing bateman's victim this way is
a powerful statement on heron's part
and it's a large reason that many
consider this film to be subversively
feminist despite popular backlash
heron forces us to acknowledge
christie's humanity to tragic effect
of course that is if you believe that
patrick bateman's serial killing really
happened
which brings us to difference number
four
reality one of the lingering questions
about american psycho
is whether or not this whole killing
spree happened in real life or took
place in bateman's rapidly
disintegrating psyche
obviously both the film and novel share
the clue that paul allen is apparently
alive and well
this clue is a little more suspect in
the novel because
everyone is constantly confusing male
identities
which happens just a few salient times
in the film
in both versions though it at least
feels possible that the lawyer merely
had dinner with someone who
looks like paul allen also both share a
creepy moment when patrick goes to clean
up allen's apartment and
meets an intimidating real estate agent
who tells patrick to go away
and don't make any trouble please in the
film this is as close as we get to a
clue
that somebody knows what he's been up to
compounded with the chilling suspicion
that this real estate agent covered up
his murders to more easily sell the
apartment
however there's one scene in the book
that is far more revealing
in it bateman's cab driver recognizes
him and calls him out as the madman who
killed a fellow cabbie named sally
he also reports that bateman's face is
on a wanted poster downtown
this literal confrontation the one time
somebody looks him in the eye and
accuses him of being a murderer
is powerful in the novel bateman says
i feel naked suddenly tiny my mouth
tastes metallic
then it gets worse clearly bateman is
cut down to size when faced with
accusations about his behavior
the cabbie then holds up a gun in rob's
bateman of his precious rolex and
wayfarers
informing him that there is no monetary
reward being offered for turning him in
it's interesting the scene is again
scathing commentary the cabbie's moral
indignation is overridden by his desire
for expensive material goods he could
try to turn bateman in
but there's no financial incentive to do
that so he doesn't bother
pretty dark but more importantly the
scene does a lot of work to suggest that
bateman's killings
are real and that he could face
consequences for
his actions the movie doesn't have this
scene and that really matters
in fact it contributes to the reasonable
belief among some fans that the killings
are actually all in patrick's head
easton ellis has said that he's not sure
himself however heron has said patrick
was
definitely a serial killer though some
of the movie's more outrageous events
were intended to be ambiguous
that said heron has commented that her
biggest regret
was people keep coming out of the film
thinking that it's all a dream and i
never
intended that the cabbie steel in a
rolex scene in the book makes bateman's
murderous inclinations less ambiguous
and pretty much assures us at least that
patrick's murder spree has some
basis in reality and speaking of rolex's
that brings us to
difference number five the rolex in the
novel bateman makes more than two dozen
references to his beloved rolex
however apparently rolex wasn't so cool
with being the favored watch of cinema's
most hideous serial killer
and wouldn't sign off on any references
as a result the movie doesn't contain
a single utterance of that most sacred
word rolex
rather when one woman reaches for
patrick's hand he merely says
touch the watch this though it seems
incidental
is actually super important because nah
just kidding it's just a fun piece of
trivia with absolutely no
bearing on the plot so sue us but what
do you guys think
do these differences change the
respective meanings of the film in the
book
which is better or is that a dumb
question because each is unique
tell us your thoughts in the comments as
always huge thanks to our patrons for
all your support
lovingly swipe that subscribe button
like you're patrick bateman applying an
anti-aging eyeball and be sure to ring
that bell
as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you